Simon we have to mention that you've
just finished filming mission impossible
5 with mr. Tom Cruise I have hours there
today I should we do if you pick up
slice cuz you're not just in it yeah you
were some properties co-starring you're
making me feel lazy yeah you're very
common I know you are you saying I wish
I could say my favorite bit was JJ lets
me improvise JJ would it wouldn't even
cross the road in vegetables because Tom
Cruise has been here and he's talked
about you know you had to say hello I
swear to God he said to say hello Thomas
he is the nicest man in the world but he
talks about doing all the stunts because
in the trailer there's that big car
chase you see a bit of it yes you are in
that car yeah we spent five days in a
BMW in Casablanca just Haring around
which got which is extremely exciting
but it got very boring in between the
takes so I realized after about three
days because it was very hot in
Casablanca but I was getting really hot
and like a little too hot and I realised
that Tom Cruise had been turning my seat
heater on wasn't looking he's far more
of a sort of ordinary chap I mean he's
no extraordinary but he's kept doing it
the whole time and he kept getting me so
good Simon get some electrolytes and
like he was hydrating me I was like
seven he was keeping me alive
he was touching me and then as soon as I
noticed him do and he do it in the
middle of a handbrake turn I decided to
get him back so I went he went to the
bathroom and I got one of the guys one
of the electricians I got some black
tape and I got this sliver of black tape
and I put it over the lights on his seat
heater and turned it on so he couldn't
see that it was on so he sat down and
was white checked it wasn't on because
the light one and then he just after
about five minutes he was going what do
you realize that I've done that he was
gave me props and he never lets you went
on so I'm allowed to win we've got
pictures of two of you in the car
Oh can you be meats with Tom Cruise or
Rizzo in love how you do fall in love
with him he's an amazing man oh yeah
very good in that you're very good in
everything
thanks man I love doing that it's what
kept you very pretty like on with the
one with the with the young the talk the
tall building in the in Dubai I thought
was brilliant yeah he did that as well
hilarious I've told you this before
every time I see you
restaurant and is this the restaurant
I smell Italian food so you had a hag
dude I had a hack do in Spain and what's
the difference in I had doing a stag do
haggis camper